[Music]
welcome to winners on a Wednesday where
we bring people every single week that
we have helped become financially free
or had their life changed through
property this week I have Josh connect
he's got a large property portfolio he's
financially free and we've been working
together for a couple years so Josh
welcome to winners on a Wednesday thank
you so much
so it's easy to be here I love the cat
man it's like his personal brand thing
I'm the guy with the hat it's it's on
the business card it's on the website
you know what the cool things about you
josh is we booked you to come on the
show a couple weeks back yeah and you
actually while driving here you've been
doing deals yeah just tell us about the
last 20 hours last 20 hours so this
morning was an early start
I got up by to hide a car because I'm a
bit big petrol head and I have our cars
and my car wasn't gonna make up here so
for 20 quid I got a hiker what while up
on the way here I actually hit the
phones I thought well I'm going this way
anyway let's see what I can do I hit the
phones I did two phone calls and raised
a hundred and fifty five grand you've
raised a hundred and fifty five grand
that's incredible thing on the way up so
that was fine yet agreed
according to Bristol on the way that's
kind of on the way and that's where I'm
building up my portfolio and doing
you've done many deals and boots a
couple of viewings sort of flats put an
offer in offer accepted numbers are 1:45
worth hundred and seventy-five it needs
it's got new brand new carpet in there
already it probably needs a boiler which
is just straight buy-to-let well we find
that sit put all as much money out of it
as I can I'll stage it refinance it and
then I'll stipple the furniture out
it'll be a buy to let as it is it will
give me over seven percent return seven
eight percent really single that's it
pull out we find that sit pull it out so
my retail investment will be 30 plus
season and if you've used someone else's
money its infamous gone yeah well I
haven't use any of my money I'm but any
of my money to any single deal of done
Wow
listen
you have been in probably the wrong time
you've had some deals go really well
yeah you had some things not go so well
absolutely why don't you just tell us
the big picture of your background and
how you got so into property and then
we're really going to dive into some of
the deals yeah of course let me tell you
the story when I was eight years old my
parrot I lived in a million pound paid
off house a lot with my parents there
was there were few of us kids and there
was an annex on the back of the house
and that's was rented out for seven
hundred quid a month so seven hundred
quid would literally come in cash in the
back door and we go into a drawer under
the phone so being seven eight years old
I'd put up the drawer and look at all
the rolls of cash that were under the
under the phone those days your phone's
attached to the wall right but I see
well the rolls of cash that was enough
to tell me if I'd bought property and
rented it out you'd make money so they
did that from property so they did that
from the annex the back of the house was
rented out the money just went into the
drawer and eventually was taken into the
bank got ya so the meantime I'd see all
the rolls of cash and I'd be like ah I
could buy a lot of sweets without her
bicycle was in whatever and you know it
was enough to get me excited to go
alright I want to do something that has
it so I left school when is the building
trade I went to college honey mother was
doing apprenticeship I was getting paid
about a hundred quid a week or something
like that and actually quit my college
course and didn't tell the boss who was
giving me the apprenticeship and when it
all came to light he said to me if you
want to make it in property this is the
minimum you're gonna need so funnily
enough me and him parted company but I
got to see a house build from the ground
up so that gave me a basic understanding
of everything that I need to know
brickwork I saw the electrics have sort
of plumbing you know I was doing all the
groundwork doing the roofing doing the
tiling being actually involved in it so
yeah from that point of view was really
really valuable now when I'm working the
trades I have a little idea of what they
meant to be do so it was nice a few
years later to be able to stand at front
of a property me he didn't recognize who
it was but I recognized him and said oh
yeah by the way I'm doing this deal I'll
do in that deal and that was just a luck
a little so he said
of what of a college certificate in
economy what it was like building or
management or automated yet to make it
in property okay no that's not true we
know that's not true but it was nice to
just go told you say everyone says this
though everyone says you need this much
money you need this qualification you've
got such experience you need this much
but actually we know how that you can as
an entrepreneur you can start with no
money no not it's no network because
I've done that I did that
so people people just look at making a
lot they do and actually I started going
to school and I had to fundraise on a
daily basis now the reason for this was
my lunch was to pound 20 than what I
wanted Pizza chips and bitters I'm
thought I was to pound 20 my parents
gave me to quit for lunch every day so
straight away I was temp essential
purpose like couldn't you just said to
them section 224 don't cut the story
short Oh God go on so straightaway I had
this problem when I had to get an extra
20 P so I would you know I would borrow
it off people I would try and get things
and Sarah I would try and find stuff to
sell it and then I was chuckling pass
the shops and I saw these sherbert
sticks right mph you get twelve for a
quid I was like amazing so I bought
quids worth and I was selling them at
school at the retail price making the
extra money for lunch once I knew I've
got enough people I was then buying to
lots of making for TP and could pay
people back I'd borrowed 20 P for and I
just started fundraising all of the time
then that deal stopped and it was like
ah I'm back to this problem again the
little problems in life but but this was
my education around fundraising and then
one day I was like ah mom could I just
have an extra 20 P for lunch
cuz you know I didn't know what was
gonna be [ __ ] oh yeah yeah alright oh
it's gonna ask I said that stylist
strike gut feeling and I did exactly the
same when I was starting out me but what
did you learn from that then just ask
ask people for money yeah ask yeah if
you know if you don't get so your
parents or the sounds of it were quite
welfare that they were they remarked as
their house and did a load of really
really bad investments and lost most of
it and we met just around or just out
I think this toilet right yeah so they
did some rubbish investments that's the
list I'd tap what why because I mean
property is obviously a really good way
to make money but you've seen firsthand
that if you do it wrong it can yeah I'm
saying then they were investing it was a
setup company that they offered off plan
investments okay yes yeah you know the
ones you know and you could go on and
you could check that you know ones did
the apartments in the area were renting
for that and it was finding the values
where that but what they were selling
you is hundreds of those and they build
them put them on the market the prices
drop no one could sell them no one could
win him hmm they also invested in Spain
just before that went and completely up
the wall and and the surveyors were over
valuing that they were working with and
it just seemed like a bit of a nice
setup for them yeah as opposed to
everyone out there was one year where
they let me a little bit of money and I
was able to give them over six grand
profit where the whole portfolio that
year made them thirty four quid so yeah
there's there was a property gave me
opportunities and a chance to give back
to them for supporting on my wedding
wonderful scheme for a couple years
yeah it's scary I mean often I think
when people will lose a lot of money on
property I always think it's usually
either off plan or overseas or there's
been a nasty joint venture partner
involved who's you know so I mean that
can happen and it's sad so when did you
start then investing in property
yourself or becoming a property
entrepreneur yourself and how did that
come about
so my wake-up call was the 2007-2008
crash yeah I was doing I was running I
was actually running motorcycle business
which I still do but my gut feeling was
with all my experience if you did
property right they paid you so 2008
happened ah I already knew about the 89
crash it was terrible house prices
dropped and I was always thinking I need
one of those to be able to buy houses no
seven or way it happened I'd done
absolutely nothing in property and I
went oh it's now and I'm missing the
boat so then it was a case of right what
am I gonna do in order to get this
opportunity working for me everyone
they are terrible you know houses don't
invest in those so the first thing I did
is I wrote a business plan I knew
exactly what I was gonna do and actually
I didn't know what it was at the time
but it was a HMO I'd rent the rooms out
I'd make extra at the time you get a
residential interest only mortgage which
is what we do first off but it was talk
to as many people as possible that
potentially had money in order to say
here's the plan this is what I think I
can achieve this is what I think the
profit will be this will be your share
the time 13:3 and all those rules
weren't as tight as they were now yeah I
could do some more creative stuff but
the point was I did the first one no
money down below market value for back
three grand and I had a really strict
criteria which was it had to have a
garage and a toilet record read the
newspaper so the first one were I did
like that I found it and I bought it so
very interesting job it's very
interesting that you saw the crash as an
opportunity because most people if it's
not all is going to be a massive crash
or there's a recession coming will be
scared by that but you actually saw that
as an opportunity why didn't that one in
that was to me I've always been the
mindset that I need to buy when
everything's cheap yeah that just that
just came naturally since I was a kid
always looking for the opportunity and
this just happened to be the big way but
most people think and it's completely
illogical but when there's a crash
people think there's been a crash and
now it's gonna get worse and how is it
going to continue it well it's actually
we know that when there's a crash it
will always be followed by an expansion
so that's the time to game yeah it is
you know my kind of inquisitive nature
was okay what happened in the 80s what
happened in the crash you know how did
everyone lose everything why did they
lose everything and what happened
afterwards yeah
and you know you can look at graphs and
whatever apps and you can see the
crashes and you can see the recoveries
there's enough times that this has
happened for me to go I don't know for
sure but the chances are the last 30 of
those it's done this there's a pretty
good chance it's going to do this you go
back up again yeah okay I made by before
it's bottomed out but if it takes me six
months a year to
to turn the investment around or get it
rented or be able to add value it takes
me a bit of time all the time that
that's going down I'm not having to sell
and then it's gonna recover at some
point when you borrow people's money
that's basically your strategy has been
I think pouring money and then investing
that money into a profitable property
deal yeah and then you give them either
a small profit share or a percentage
return on investment for their deal yeah
the whole thing so your strategy has
that all been smooth sailing you have
there been bad things that have gone
wrong
nothing's ever smooth sailing thankfully
I've never done a deal that's lost me
money yeah okay I've done a couple of
deals that didn't quite go as smoothly
as we'd hoped
yeah let's get this I saw this really
amazing guy called Samuel Leeds who sold
me a property deal and it's been nothing
but hassle get out of here however it
has made me about 30 40 grand so I can
because I did sell your deal more Banton
yeah how many years ago three years ago
something like about three years ago
what went wrong you say it was a sales
hassle oh yeah so any property deal
hazards quirks yeah you know I'm just
winding up really but the things that
went wrong every disability works so
there's major damp all the way through
so we ripped the - there's a part and
did the damp about 10 egg she's sure
it's bath to guarantee yeah that's that
was the first thing that was fine and
then to complete the renovations I
called in a builder who had done a
previous project for me I said there you
go we know what to do we work together
before everything was fine but the plan
by the way sorry was to buy it spend a
bit of money on it
yeah rent is a HMO and then we financed
it yes yes so so so far you've bought it
everything's fine you've got a builder
on start yeah we got a builder outside
so a few months into the project my mum
passed away and this was enough to allow
me to take my eye off the ball I had a
father who was ill at home and so a
couple of things going on and so had
having worked with the Builder before
I then said can you just run the site
yeah I've had a family loss you know
where most of the way through can you
just do it and on a regular basis he'd
phone me out and go yeah I've done this
I've done this I've done this penis end
the next payment so I said you know 8 to
10 grand in chunks over a couple of
months when I was dealing with all the
family stuff only to find that when I
went up there nothing had been done
since the moment I left and and he had
lots of holiday pictures on Facebook
which was a bit of a coincidence you
know so you know that is not a great
know great thing especially when I was
dealing with you know all the other
stuff it allowed me to go right tighten
up my systems and that's actually one
okay all right Samri leads help me out
okay running dude I'm having a disaster
can you just manage this build and I
think I just went there are the keys you
sought to be the property sort it out
I'll pay you later yeah
and you went yeah man no problem yeah I
wonder at the time you know we said I
mean the property was it was a good
house
it was great house and we sorted it I
think we've read five or six properties
yeah at the time this one it did have a
really small room but actually we could
Nick a bit yeah putting up I remember
the house and then you know obviously
you had yeah the build was doing that
thing on it and when when you when you
called me and told me what was going on
about the builders of basically
abandoned the job they've taken my money
I'm losing money on the house I've lost
when your mom had passed away
I remember just sort of saying look come
to the office bring the keys and then
we'll sort yeah I don't even think we
challenged you actually for that yeah I
think we came to some agreement yeah
yeah it was it was you know I think and
I think it just shows what builders can
be not only sloppy but that's almost
evil man yeah I mean to be fair he he's
paying me back that he's got CCJ against
his name bit by bit actually the
agreement was he was gonna pay me a
pound a month so you took him in you
took him to court what well what the
fact that you had to do that when you
mom's just passed away
yeah and so you know this is that this
is about as bad as it can get oh no
again
had worse times but this was this was
the worst one on the project yeah so so
then eventually yeah I think we paid the
builders to do it again we rented that
as I hate Jim oh yeah we got that
everything was going fine a couple of
months in there was a guy who was
constantly drinking you know throwing
stuff around like up all night arguing
with his girlfriend who I didn't even
know was living there at the time
because I've got someone has to manage
it and it all came to a head when I got
a phone call about two o'clock in the
morning or something there your tendons
are beating up his girlfriend in the
middle of the street you know outside
the house
okay this would explain why so many
people have come in and then gone again
because it only takes one bad apple
juice yeah the pie or whatever yeah so
so that was a bit of a thought okay so
let's have a rethink and actually we
changed everything to serviced
accommodation so you change the house to
a serviced accommodation here yeah and
then the first thing I managed to do was
get a six-month contract with some
workers that are in the area they were
staying there and they'll pay me 500
pounds a week yeah amazing and you know
and it's been interesting story though
so I mean what what are the lessons from
that I mean firstly the Builder leaving
site I mean because you can't physically
yeah I mean what we do is we have a
project manager a project manager yeah
that's what I don't totally because you
can't physically be on site but if
you're not and no one is the filters
will take the mick of course it will you
know and if you're not there they'll
even if they do turn out their turn up
at any game with - yeah and that kind of
thing you do need someone on site
managing the project but without the
tenants like what did you learn from the
whole experience of having this terrible
tenant that was just reporting all the
other tenants so it's actually about
being a little bit more choosy yeah
because of all everything that was going
on you want the house yet have you got
the money yet or I coming at the time it
was like it was a bit hectic it's and
you know in all of that
there were lots of things that I would
let slip because of this
situation that would never normally have
happened so it was just is there's never
one thing that goes wrong with two or
three that makes a whole situation yeah
but actually my biggest learning was
it's about you seen yeah as if you were
on your own yeah so what sort of people
you you team you need to stop that kind
of thing happening so well to be honest
people like yourself people in the area
people that can take on what you can't
manage at the time yeah and this was my
introduction into outsourcing actually
so I now have someone in the Philippines
that does all of my admin all of my
invoicing anything that I don't need to
be in the country to do gets outsourced
to the Philippines yes and that's been a
revelation in this and what you find
them on play cut work I actually went to
a friend of mine called Imogen cook yeah
you guys are welcome to check them out
anyone who's watching on on YouTube she
actually puts adverts on Filipino jobs
arts or she I think we had 700 so what
had once a v8 and she created this Hopf
system from a Filipino website to create
tasks and I think her English friends
were getting about 80 85 percent right
in the test and the Filipinos were
getting 90 and above for the people that
she'd hired Wow so not only a lot
cheaper but they're doing a better job
yeah doing a much better job Wow and
actually when I had my first
conversation I was like well what I want
you to do is go into Excel and put this
in here and then see it okay do want me
to do an excel or an eyedropper to just
attach an email fire it across to you
afterwards and I went oh okay you're
really good because when you're running
like you're running quite a large
property portfolio you've got lots of
tenants you did lots deals you do need
it gets to a point if you're doing two
or three say but if you've got double
digits it gets to a point where you need
someone to absolutely otherwise is just
a job if you're is all the admin and
you're it's just it because because even
if you've got property managers in place
just managing the property managers and
keeping track of all the rents and the
IFC on tracks it's a job so you do need
people I mean I've got offices and staff
but so what you're doing is almost like
the the 4-hour workweek
yeah
absolutely I've read it and I love it
and I'll put in as as much of that into
my business as a possible ironically
takes more than four hours to read the
4-hour work it does yeah actually I had
it on audio so when I was going there
please don't eat us so now that property
then is that still renting out monsters
I still haven't refinanced it yeah how
much do you buy for a hundred and five
to fifty when doing [ __ ] what was it a
specific figure remember because I well
it's because they go to the assumption
that we've done our calculations to the
number yeah if you say I think he was on
flat one to five it was it was yeah you
very good it was all at one to five wait
for quite a while yeah it's been on for
at least six months and I think it
started at 135 or something they'd come
down to a point and then then if we do
come on us it will give you 105 that a
property said make it 100 and 10 or me
its initial at 115 but if we say 105 to
5th day because it's super specific yeah
they just thought why you've obviously
done your numbers yeah and you get any
to find a month's rent for that not bad
how much makes it worth now what would
the value be now 150 grand not bad
so despite all the problems that warm up
absolutely it's worth it in the end we
get so used to doing all these property
deals you know phoning up boring money
and making offers and stuff we forget
that the average wage in the UK is about
30 grand four years worth of work yeah
30 35 grand I you know haven't heard
recently but that's roughly where you're
at and you've made more than that on
this morning deal yeah I think it's
about time you refinance that deal you
know it yeah it's gonna happen
yeah happened towards the end of the
year so so that's this one deal which we
have which was our nightmare but you
know what as well from my point of view
because I know I sold you the property
icon I'm in matter how much may be tuned
off thousand or something yes but I'm
more heating you were talking at working
pin yeah and so now I've got this deal
because we were taking it okay you know
what are you up to what you're talking
about
and so I've got this deal okay where is
it you know if you want it you've sent
me to the hot grand I went all right
then
yeah and that was it but you paid me on
trust without even seen it but then but
then that I then have to
a certain weight of responsibility when
dealing with other people's running
after yeah and even though you paid me
and you haven't even seen it you went
out saw it it's fine because you paid me
on trust I've now got the responsibility
to make sure that as a client you're
looked after and that's why absolutely
and you know and that you know that was
worth the two-and-a-half grand to me
yeah I mean that's later you have some
problems I'm gonna do what I can of
course when you sort of don't do source
properties for the people I do but as
you can tell I don't source that money
out because I kind of hit the phones go
ahead I found a property do you want to
fund it yeah and I love buying them and
then some flipping some and yeah so but
when you do though when you do source
properties I think it's so important
that yeah I mean you're right I mean not
to do it anymore and the reason all
those sorts of properties anymore is
because I've got so many students that
do it
I don't want to compete with my own
students I'd rather my investors buy off
my students than bar off me now yes
that's whatever to do anymore but I
think you know when you do you've just
got to make sure don't don't pass
anything all the human by yourself no
absolutely okay or just by yourself if
you can if you know the skill of raising
finance like you do then then by
yourself yeah you know absolutely I mean
the last thing is something like the
flat C of C that I've bought today in
Bristol or had offer except a lot you
can pay someone a substantial amount of
interest after you've refurbed it in
refinance you still make your money and
I've got equity in the property if I pay
that even if I paid about all the profit
I have a property that is infinite
tenant on my infinite return on my money
yeah because there's none of my any
money that's this is happy and guess
what when they give them back give the
money back to them and go hey well
that's good you undo again they go hell
yeah I asked Robert Kiyosaki recently on
an interview what'd he do he was
starting all over again with a hundred
thousand pounds or hundred thousand
dollars
and his response was well I wouldn't
need two hundred thousand dollars yeah
you don't because I need to fire up you
just raise it or you know oh yeah it's
kind of irrelevant having the hundred
thousand dollars which I thought was a
really interesting answer and you're
you're living proof of that so okay so
what do you do right and what sort
probably is he buying at the moment so I
am
I'm actually switching a lot of my
portfolio to single let yeah interesting
because I've been refinance out you know
initially you buy for tax flow you want
to get you know as much money as
possible to to fund your lifestyle
effectively yeah but once you get to the
point where you're all buying or
refinancing paying people out actually
an easier life becomes that's slightly
more important so so are you gonna keep
holding your HMOs yeah but you from now
on moving forward you just gonna stop
one single that yeah by single let's
yeah I'm going to eventually I will be
turning my HMOs into two flats okay
because people stay about nine months at
hector mode they stay a couple of years
at least enjoying the flat suddenly if
it's a for cash flow HMOs extremely good
you cannot do no but they are hard and
work to manage
yes been single that's that's also
undeniable so depends for you if you're
starting out and you're buying your
first few properties with the sole
intention of getting as much cash flow
as you can to leave your job HMOs are
great but when you've got a whole bunch
of high Tomos you're financially free I
know you're still working but you do it
because I think you love the motorbikes
which is cool but yeah that makes sense
so these these in Bristol know you want
apartment so these are yeah well the one
today it's a two major flat it's
actually on a couple of levels mmm
it's had brand new carpet you know
already I mean it's a water tank as
opposed to a little boiler but because
it's not running radiators I can just
put the the smallest what's the boy
doing there how do I know you bought it
below market value
yeah how are you going to read finance
say if you've not added any value to it
I will add value to it but well firstly
it's it's a good price yeah it is the
the second thing is paint and staging
yeah make a lot of difference sure
so usually meaning so it will be like a
hotel you'll have towels on the beds
that are you know goose or whatever yeah
you'll have furniture that is even even
IKEA people say to me you know how do I
staged a property because these women do
it amazingly
no no I'm generalizing but they have the
art type woman's touch yeah totally
and I don't have that
but what I do know is IKEA spend
thousands of thousands of pounds getting
designers to make sex yeah that cell
yeah so why am I gonna reinvent the
wheel I'm gonna go and buy everything
there and I'm gonna stick it in my house
interesting if they're selling it I can
sell my house on it that's very
interesting
yeah so rather than playing an interior
designer to help you just drop it from
one Kia yeah and yet for goodness sake
get them to come and build it as well
yeah if they don't come and build it get
someone whose business is to build it
because there's nothing worse than IKEA
furniture if you're a property investor
it's a drug inside I used to flap back
just just a few rooms I've been there on
my hands and knees back in the day we're
interested also interested in I don't
know what your experiences but when you
when you buy the property to refinance
it back in the day when we started out
you could just buy a B&E below market
value and then we finance it cook it now
you got to add value yeah all bite this
this or buy it below current market
value yeah even though sometimes valuers
if you're not found value as weather say
you bought it for this and you therefore
that's the new value yes but whenever I
have an evaluation I will create a pack
for my value yeah it's not often that
they turn it down it will be all the
local stores in the area yeah all the
things that anything behind desirable
undisputable evidence that this is the
value so that the value uh almost feels
completely stupid try not to run yeah I
guess they don't they don't have to do
their job I've done it the end of them
in the notice way but evaluate that I've
created a pack for will see that I've
done my market research there are five
ten souls within the court now that I
can prove that I can go and challenge
their evaluation well happily take you
on here's my folder yeah it's also
giving reasons to why you bought it so
cheap as well and even say look all the
point of uncle folio or this was the
personal situation yanking you and you
can justify it another thing as well
just that I find it really interesting
is that there's more ways to add value
to a house than just doing it up you can
also that if there's a problem with the
lease or if there's a flying free home
issue or there's absolutely a covenant
restriction or all revaluing it by
on commercial so if you've now writing
it as a business and you can print the
rent
HMOs a commercial yeah commercial
funding is a whole different ballgame
but actually I find it's easier
you hit commercial funding firm I hate
to moans then it is so the passivity
questions are their names number one how
can I get this property cheaper well how
can I follow motivates earth so I can
block roads below market value
yeah and the number two is how can I add
as much value to this property as
possible so that I can then refinance it
and pull my money out yeah absolutely
are you are you planning on putting all
your money out of this deal yeah that's
a cool that's all it's it's about doing
as many as I can
yeah but obviously being Tuesday about
it but the nice thing is about property
if you buy something that's really
really rubbish and you've ever paid for
it time forgives your property mistake
so as long as you don't have to sell it
in the middle of a crash yeah it's it's
almost forgivable well you can the thing
is unless you're forced to sell a
property yeah you're just gonna sell it
a good time yeah so absolute you don't
have to sell it
we've you just hold it absolutely yeah
absolutely and so yeah one of my one of
my things is never put myself in the
situation where I've overstretched any
particular LTV load 2 value on a
property it's like like I will pull out
all of my money to buy another deal I
will not use my portfolio as a catch me
I got ya
so important because people pull out
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
pounds and you know I sit down with a
lot of property people and you know if
they're looking to vote with me I'm
gonna mana see you know that current
portfolio to make sure that high net
worth because yeah
in some of the rules you have to be a
certain level to be able to get a
variable outcome yeah so they need to
have basically two hundred and fifty
grams worth of equity so show me your
portfolio and I sit down with people and
I look at their portfolio and they put
so much money out if there's a 1% rise
currently it's the lowest interest rates
I've ever seen a 1% rise they make their
money yeah and it's like I'm not doing
this yeah bang on preach bro you just
are doing it's so important because if
you're making a good cash flow then it
doesn't matter
interest rates due to a point to a port
or just fix interest rates and pay down
your mortgages 50 quid yeah actually to
do that it's not gonna kill you cash
flow well there are actually thousands
of pounds over the long term
yeah I'll Eric I personally don't
recommend paying off your mortgage until
you're financially free because the
supposed goal has to be financial
freedom yeah everything's gone it's time
you gotta have the timeline few
everybody thinks depth free members I
think financially for it everyone wants
to be dead flies stupid yeah as long as
I'm making money from it mmm actually
the new the new landlord tax we've got
some more video yeah he's very clever
cuz it's a tax on deck which you know if
the government didn't tax debt you know
they'll be making a lot more money than
it's a first time I've ever seen that be
it's the first time I've ever seen that
being the case yeah it was trialed in
Australia and and there was one other
country I can't remember where it was
but they pulled it very soon afterwards
mmm because actually the the government
relies a lot on us as landlords
providing houses for people and what
they forget is we take stuff this
sometimes unlivable yeah and bring it
back into yeah life yeah they just don't
see that the only way you're gonna make
money is by adding value yeah you know
so let me ask you a question then you've
obviously had some sort of challenges
and you've overcome them yes what have
been the biggest lessons that you've
drawn because I know you're a real
dealer you've you've obviously done a
lot of education you know you've been
through my training yeah um which
hopefully you found good I will be here
for the biggest lessons the biggest
lessons is is don't be scared to say no
yeah no it's a really great answer and
and the more you say it the less hassle
you wake yourself with but when it comes
to training be very careful where you
put your money and just make sure that
you're talking to someone that's doing
what they are preaching sure cuz you've
done a few different training program
I'm a fan of training because I actually
put into practice what people teach yeah
I'm prepared to give it a go there's
there's a lot of people that you know
come on lots of courses and don't but
for me they're actually adding massive
value and if I get a couple of Nuggets
that make me a couple of grand extra on
if you have yes it's worth it so I think
training totally has its place the the
thing that I don't like is that the huge
selling sell aminals yeah yeah yeah you
credit card and buy of course yes the
first thing I ever did when I got my a
bit of money was to go on of course
they've got you to up you I I didn't
have any money I had a credit card hotel
about two grand on it and they said fold
them up you credit card sure enough up
to 20 grand it went and they said great
you could buy the course and you know
and that was my first half disappeared
yeah and actually from that course I got
no more value than I would have done
going to pin meetings and that kind of
thing yeah I'm not prepared about anyone
or anything like that no but it the my
lesson was be very careful with your
money yeah you know what I think I mean
I I run training some of it's free some
of its pay of course but I really agree
you I wouldn't ask anyone to go on any
of my paid for training until they've
got a whole ton of value first from
lifeless training yes that's how we roll
and and then I love I love that that you
give so much to the point where people
if they pull their finger out they can
actually go and do it yeah but what
people what people get stuck on it in my
experience certainly from you know when
I mentoring people they know what to do
they just don't know how to do it mmm
and and then once you told them how to
do it they don't necessarily do it
unless you give them kicked out the bar
yeah yeah yeah and that's when ok you
know what to do and and it becomes you
you're kind of encouraging them you're
paying me go and do the stuff you'll get
the results and then it becomes
important enough because they paid for
it for them to actually do the stuff and
they yeah I mean I charge for some
training because I think that if you if
you don't pay for it you don't value it
the same way yes and that's why I mean
we've run the property investors crash
course and that our success rates are
really high but on the pay difficult
raining it's it's even higher yeah you
know you get people that by putting a
barrier to entry or you're in the nicest
way pushing out the tyre Theus well yeah
I mean yeah it's it's an interesting
it's an interesting one but I think the
most important aspect
is that it make sure if you're paying
someone to mentor you or to train you
make sure that do it it yeah you know
that's the biggest thing like that's the
biggest I live and breathe property on
the field all the time yep so I think
that kind of qualifies me to teach it
absolutely but yeah absolutely so what's
the next big things than London for you
what what are you what are you going to
do those problems the next 12 months
probably five deals okay I don't want to
go to mental yes I've got a few things
for me personally that I want to achieve
which is gonna take a little bit money
out of the the property yeah anything
beautiful
yeah fairly beautiful what I've always
what the reason I started a property
business was to buy an f-35 five Ferrari
Spyder know like how much I buy so
they're ready to a 2016 100 grand okay
so it's not undoable yeah but it's hard
to justify we know so much but I can get
I can buy two houses with that hundred
grand I get 800 pounds a month yeah you
know what I'd so it's so I've just
bought my odd just for the first time
ever I've just bought my first luxury
car in the past I've rented or just you
know yeah and it was it up until this
point I was able to just fight now but I
think until you are ultimately
financially free and ever saw that like
you the fact that you've held off until
this point I'm sure you definitely could
have afforded it but you haven't because
you always want to live below your means
yeah and it's so difficult because as
you say if you think I can spend this
icy ground on one two houses which is
going to make me you know I intricate a
month or whatever or I could use it to
buy a car which is going to depreciate
you last time I checked it's not gonna
give me any rent I've got it's a hard
it's hard to do parties especially as
the my mindset is invest for the
long-term
yeah and that kind of but there comes a
point where you go I found military blog
so yeah in the between now and twelve
months time you know I'd like to do that
that's great
was he but yeah it's it's that's on the
cards so what's up besides driving a
Ferrari and what you wish it was
strongest reason why why
why are you in this business well I mean
this business um I I live in brief
property I love it it is exciting
because it gives me profits it's
exciting because I get feed off other
people really enjoying it if they're
going out doing the same thing yeah I
get excitement from that in the long
term you know I do want to put some put
some charities there's gonna be time
he's going to suddenly become my friend
I'm gonna have lots of time so that I
can do the things I want but also I can
help other people out starting at the
bottom with be where I was 10 years ago
and then there is the other side of
things where I like to give back and
yeah I don't publicly say at all but
there was a time where I was living in
the shed in the on the side of the train
tracks and accordant yeah nowhere to go
you didn't have any money and it was
like okay I need to like pull my finger
out how does that happen and there was a
couple of situations that that came
together so I had effectively put some
I'd invested all my money which was
great that was working I wasn't
necessarily doing the right thing I
wasn't getting any cash flow that
support me and in the early days I had
given up everything to look after my
parents then when they passed away we
had we were in a rented house at the
time because of the rubbish investments
I had a basic dad I paid all my money to
cover up my part of the rent for the
next year
look solely looking after my parents and
then when my mum passed away and my dad
went into care I had nothing nothing
left and I was its I was living in what
was left of an old Mondeo I was sleeping
in a shed in Croydon now there's two
things you could be Omar it was terrible
how terrible I wanna move it was - a tin
winter and that was pretty cold but I
had a car and I had a shed and I would
go to my local boat yard because I can
go and have a shower six o'clock before
they opened up I could then drop my
stuff at the dry cleaners
pick up my new clothes get changing
money on clothes and then I'll Drive to
property events ago I'm doing property
you know and if you want to come and
have a coffee you know let's talk about
investments and no one ever knew what
was going on in the background
I mean thankfully it was temporary and
quite a long time ago but it was like
I'm never ever going back to that point
and that gives you massive masses of
Drive that's incredible so I mean was
there a point your parents lost an awful
lot of money
you then had to support them and when
they've been living almost almost
verging on homelessness you then
borrowed money to put into a deal with
me which looked like it was gonna be a
disaster or important when the builders
jump [ __ ] you know I mean at that point
did you ever wonder is this really gonna
work out every week you know like am i
completely insane and my mindset was
like okay you're either gonna go under
what are you gonna make it and but if I
can say that I tried and I do absolutely
everything yeah I can start again
because I have people that will lend me
money
yeah and that was enough tonight if it
doesn't work out I will recover if I
lose the money I'll pay them back I will
succeed one my own it makes it even
worse when not only have you lost your
own money because you've been looking
after your parents but when people have
lent you money to invest it it's thick I
never lost anyone money I've always 100
percent of the time I know I can I can
only I know I know you spoke to me at
that point you know you came to this
office
there's off the keys off weakness me but
to think we're how far you've come in
three years you know and then what you
do now and you own these properties
you're financially free you've not lost
any money on them no I have you paid
back your investors yes and actually at
the beginning of this year I paid nearly
mm power back to my investors refinance
because I had I had one property that
was owned outright and I'd used that as
a first charge to then buy other
properties and then once I've done a few
and I kind of got enough investors on
board and over time I decided that
earlier this year I've refinanced that
one put all the money out right that one
port 473 HM oh you family rented renter
thank you very much so I paid me 800
quid a month for who's bought cash
there's no Bobby doing that so that I
did that for a couple of been there for
you don't have you've definitely helped
me out massively yeah what would you say
to someone that was considering maybe
there are a low point in their life and
they were considering come into the
property investors crash course cool no
that was I think healthier it was
awesome I I totally recommend it there's
there's one thing that I say to everyone
come along if you're gonna do it yeah if
you're gonna do this stuff come do it
and take action if you're not gonna
bother don't waste your time coming just
stay at home watch your standards yeah
it dead-enders London that's true that's
true because at the end of the day
you're you've come on the show to
inspire people and share your story
because what I try and do share stories
all we can do is give people the tools
absolute limit late you've got to do the
work and and it is constant work work
it's not it's not easy it's simple but
so easy yeah yeah yeah but you can do it
I started with nothing low property
experience no money and guess what I
still not paid any fired money in and
I'm building up a portfolio I think if
you've got money to invest
you can do it passively it's nice and
easy yeah if you've got no money no
experience no network no you can still
do it when you go roll your sleeves up
yeah absolutely I had hundreds and
hundreds of coffees with people saying
I've got these really amazing investment
I found do you want to invest
yeah and I screwed up so many coffees
until I created a system and and it goes
back to you have to ask for money for
you know going back 20 P I had to ask
the investor for money I was doing loads
of coffees and there are a it's really
interesting but I wasn't going do you
want to
yeah until I had answered every question
that was ever gonna be asked in the
right way and then asked for the money I
didn't get any investors so then I
created a system where yeah I'd meet you
X number of times then we have coffee
one coffee - coffee three coffee one is
what do you want to do where are you
coffee - is this is everything that's
been going wrong and I have a dedicated
coffee to go
yeah you will find dry rot we all find
out we will find this we will find that
we're working together we're going to
look at it and I will say these are my
two options I suggest you go with this
one and we're gonna work
shoulder-to-shoulder this is a business
relationship and the third coffee is
this is all the money you gotta make do
you want to sign up or in the nicest way
so I'm gonna have coffee with someone
out because yeah people out there with
money then there are doing amazing
property deals like us yeah that's great
I love how you've learned from the not
even mistakes but I mean I guess it's
scored teach you not to don't make
mistakes and that's kind of bad but in
business and in real life and the steak
is good it's just a learning point
tomorrow Dennis it's brilliant
yeah yeah school you like you say drums
- don't make a mistake I mean actually
it I'm completely dyslexic right so
school was a complete nightmare but
actually it allowed me to become a
natural problem solver because if I'm
writing a sense and I get a word I can't
spell or change the word or change the
sentence yeah you're constantly going
okay I'll do it this way that way the
government brings in another rule ok
well I'll do it this way
say I'm constantly adapting and that's
always been something I've been really
good at and as well as obviously
spotting the opportunities which which I
pulled all together a VA to do all the
admin work and ironically tech
misspelling I have a group of sources
yeah you were one of them and when you
were sourcing to outsource that I've now
systemized the sourcing and my VA in the
Philippines sends me every week a
spreadsheet of all the deals that we my
criteria which is just delicious
so that's when suddenly things became
faster quicker better and it's like the
drew drew drew and and I could focus on
the thing that I love which was
networking yeah I'm going hey guys look
at this do you want to invest this is
what I think is gonna happen in the
hears of the risks these are the
documents I need to
you to sign you know if you're sourcing
property you need anti money laundering
regulations you need liability insurance
you know there's a whole lot of things
that you want to do but that will cost
you probably less than a couple of grand
so if you sell one deal you covered your
costs yeah yeah and it's brilliant and
it's great seeing how you've snowboard
you know your successes is getting
bigger and bigger so thank you so much
for coming on the show pleasure it's
always good to see you and look forward
to continue working with you thank you
so much thanks ok thank you so much for
watching the video that is the reason
why I'm doing this your success is my
oxygen every single week we've got
people becoming financially free if
you'd like to see more success units you
can do that right here but what I'd
really suggest is why don't you come and
join us at the property investors crash
course comment on my guest completely
free and I'll personally be there for 2
days to help you get started you can see
what happens right here what you'll
notice is all of these stories they all
start at the crash course so come along
my guests can't wait to see you there
peace out